well back in the 90s all the young girls
fell in love with Leonardo DiCaprio I
mean what a cutie he wasn't and as we
celebrate our 35th season well we are
looking back at that amazing decade on
the big screen ET was on the tab for all
the biggest movies
that's candidate Kennedy's beautiful in
2000 this is it man I'm an amateur
at all one wonderful thing about the 90s
those big stars who weren't that big yet
not afraid to let their guard down with
us this tie I feel like it is kind of
cool actually but we're gonna be on
Entertainment Tonight Tom Hanks and Rob
Reiner got their groove on during our
Sleepless in Seattle set visit we're
about to knock off a few people upstairs
I'm seriously here's a set secret John
Travolta who's played a hitman in
Quentin Tarantino's Pulp Fiction didn't
know a lot about guns how you did that
with your everything I know I know you
like Linc Entertainment Tonight film you
not knowing what you're doing with a
good John did know how to dance however
yeah
oh yes now we're gettin it this is like
just a space pylon basically one guy who
did know his gear was Will Smith and men
in black this is a intergalactic space
molecular air dispersing hair dryer
slash and cool will was already very
cool I made this look good hi
Entertainment Tonight I'm Jennifer Lopez
but here's another set surprise a
Jennifer playing the late pop star in
Selena didn't actually sing in the movie
I'll be lip-syncing awesome I've got a
thing are some dancers I'd be singing in
the mic be over here yeah oh come on eat
up
I'm the bus driver and Sandra didn't
drive the bus a stunt driver did yeah
speed with the movie then they pull like
a star I just know that I'm working and
you know the films aren't bombing the
film that made Jim Carrey a star was Ace
Ventura pet detective there's electric
emery board
Augsburg gotta have one for Jim's
co-star was a relatively unknown
Courtney Cox love interest but three
years later on screen Courtney was a big
star signing autographs on the set after
all by then friends had been on the air
for two seasons this couldn't be further
from Monica what are you doing between
scenes if David Arquette's working then
pretty much you don't have to do
anything you just sit back and watch
Courtney met David making screen in
three years they would marry she's uh
stunning to look at hmm you see me
falling about five minutes Angelina
Jolie met her future husband Johnny Lee
Miller
now of elementary on the set of their
film hackers they would marry two years
later we're on the crew site-to-site the
world at the moment when we went to the
set of there's something about Mary
Cameron Diaz had already been dating
co-star Matt Dillon for two years with
Matt and I we enjoy each other and I
don't think there's any pressures that I
put on him or he puts on me for that
sort of you know that next step
unfortunately that next step was
breaking up which they did shortly after
the film wrapped I like this place a lot
everything's really inexpensive which I
like the most
it was Mexico City that 21 year old
Leonardo DiCaprio was raving about while
shooting the Romeo and Juliet wedding
his co-star Claire Danes was only 16
well he's brilliant and he's actually
I'm me
what he does as is the case now forleo
wedding bells back then weren't a big
must for me to get married now would
take a lot marriage would wouldn't be in
even my realm